[Music]
very pleasant night for baseball here in
the gateway city as the home stand
continues from busch stadium
it's game one of three between the
washington nationals they are one in
five
and the st louis cardinals who check in
at five and four but luscious mane of
john gant
look at this bad boy rolling today the
starting pitching
uh has not been the overall numbers have
not been great for the cardinals gant
last time out four innings against the
marlins
7 46 in washington and victor robles
takes the first pitch of the game
deep right up against the wall
center fielder carlson has to go for a
long way to go
and victor rogles into third with a
stand-up triple
juan soto here's where you want to seal
the deal on the run right here
but let's see what they give him to hit
breaking ball
base hit nats are on top juan soto
drives in his fifth run of the year
it was a rough one for eric fetty
against the braves in his first outing
fetty wasn't really supposed to be in
the rotation this year but with all the
issues
he's plugged in the hyundai pitch
arsenal for eric fetty a lot of two-seam
fastballs
2-2 got him
fold him on a slider that dropped back
in there
good inning for eric fetty gomes fetty
so it's the battery and then the center
fielder john gomez up there hacking base
hit
and he's three for five to start the
season two balls and two strikes
and he got him first strikeout for john
gann
the pitch on the way a swing and
a mess he got him he got him
through the change up and struck out
turner two walks in the inning now the
bases are loaded
well josh bell up in a huge spot for his
second nat's a b
[Applause]
gets out of the jab
[Applause]
he has his first hit drops down the bun
on a 3-1 pitch in the first hit
of the season for matt carpenter that's
what i'm talking about right there
take advantage of something right you
got nobody on the left side he drops
down a beauty fed he tries to make a
nice play on it yaddy's pumped up for it
you know matt carpenter
a little weight lifted how about a base
hit and tie this game up
now carpenter's at second base two outs
tommy edmond grounded out to their
shortstop trey turner in the first
inning and it's a base head into right
center
tommy edmond with a two-out hit to bring
in carpenter ever tied 1-1
tommy edmond with two outs covers this
pitch away
shoots it right through the hole we got
ourselves a tie ball game that's a
beautiful thing right there
gomes on a pitch up two for two
and on the season four for six
confetti is going to probably try to
sacrifice again with the dugout
screaming right there
stay hot yawn gomes that's the patented
yon gome swing right
get on top going the other way foot down
early little knee tuck can go trying to
quit pitching
so he keeps stepping out and i think dan
belino's telling you out of here let him
get in the box
[Music]
yeah so he can do that soto two for two
on for the third time
he's hitting on his own terms isn't it
soto not running oh my what a take
bottom of the zone two on nobody out
good at bats
here's schwarber after the mound visit
looking for his first hit
and he drives it to right center the
nets will take the lead
soto scores bell heading for third
and welcome to the ball club kyle
schwarber
rbi double 2-1 washington
that was real kyle that was not virtual
you just hit a double and drove in a run
and gave your team the lead
kyle schwarber with his first knock as a
washington national fastball up and away
pulls it into the gap
perfectly placed josh spelled a third
juan soto scores easily
that's take the lead dug out loving it
and then he's going over to third base
he's like my heart was beating a million
miles an hour
don't forget it's their opening day
we've talked about it at the beginning
of the ball game
so two runners in scoring position
startling's driven in four runs saw
first pitch fastball
sending edmond over into foul ground
he makes a good throw off line
that's a tough play for a right fielder
and bell scores
castro delivers the nats lead three to
one
so two quick outs and now yadier molina
and the 2-2 he gives it a ride into
right
center goodbye
still doing it the nissan drive of the
game off the bat of yadier molino
yachty going oppo right here just lets
this thing trap that's big time power
this thing doesn't just barely get over
the fence
that's big time pop from yachty
go ahead and get you some 1999th
game he's hitting in the four hole he's
dropping bombs opposite field
go ahead young man andrew stevenson
or stevenson lifting one deep right
center
c u later bullpen for andrew
and the nats get that run right back
somebody say what a manager someone said
wow what a manager and then that stuck
out
that's his fourth career home run i did
not see that coming
four to two nets andrew stevenson the
secret
weapon goes deep off the bench nice up
the middle a few steps
back in case there's a double play
opportunity
and instead it's a base hit castro puts
the nats on top by
three and that's his fifth rbi of the
year
lead off walk comes back to haunt
1-1 that breaking ball is another base
hit schwarber around
third the bases will be loaded as he
returns to the bag
and the nets line is moving with nobody
out
here in the eighth
popped up
center field catch made throw to the
plate
and goodbye it's a double plan a strike
from
center field and dylan carlson
on a line right to yachty
double play and the tying run will come
to the plate in kisner
fastball swing and a miss and the nats
hold on to win it
that'll break the losing streak first
win on the road trip juan soto
a three hit four time on base night and
the gnats take care of the cardinals
five to two